or not you know i'm like always standing
now in my mind because you're living out
of fear though because i just got out of
a traumatic experience i know but you
realize like if you make the next guy
pay for it there won't be a next guy
yeah true because like it's like a guy
like looking through your phone because
his last girlfriend she did
yeah you know like you're like what did
i do
i just feel like i'm now i'm blessing
with holy water every day you know
everything not anymore honestly because
it was my first and last
and last narcissist
but
what i'm saying is i think i think
though back to like the conversation is
that
women should be afraid to hit men and
we're not
well women should be afraid to hit him
like like the way that men know that if
they hit a woman their ass is going to
jail like women should have that same
fear because it's not okay
yes and like there was a guy who just
died the other day because his
his wife like beat him to death
basically yeah
and she walked
and there's no outrage yeah what yeah
she didn't got
jail time the same thing like what
happened with the actor or the um only
fans model in florida oh she yeah like
she killed she killed her boyfriend oh
yeah yeah
and she walked and even because there
are some reports that maybe like they
were both like again the majority of
domestic abuse cases they're abusing
each other like it's usually not just
one but even say that was happening like
if we reverse the roles right and he
killed her he would not have walked but
she does
and it's just like we live in this
society where like women are just
like babied honestly just because we're
women and i'm so tired of these hoes
and we're not dainty at all i completely
agree with that statement i don't know
why it's like that it's ridiculous
because we've come so far with these
metoo movements and
you know women having more power girl
power power to the people and all of
that stuff but then we're still treated
you know like back in the 60s or 50s
yeah i think
i think women
hit men because they know they're not
going to get in trouble i'm like
look
if you hit if you hit anybody
it's fair game i i don't care you asked
for it like if you're going to hit
somebody
you're opening the door for them to hit
come back and hit you
it's it's a hard reality to understand
but you shouldn't hit somebody and not
uh expect somebody to retaliate on you
you're putting them in a position to
where they're gonna have to let their
anger out some other way and you may not
know how that way is going to happen and
it comes back and it's worse than if
they would have hit you and so i don't i
don't think anybody should hit anybody
unless you want the repercussions of if
you hit somebody
if it's to protect yourself always
defend yourself because you should if
it's self you know i understand it's
self defense definitely
um but if it's not of course i'm not i'm
not a person that is violent i don't
like to attack people i don't like to
you know act on
being physical but
i
um
i had an experience and i have to
self-defense myself
and yeah i almost kill him
almost don't get
scared i didn't kill him and i didn't
walk away okay
don't worry i didn't got there
no
it's scary
but i had to protect myself
okay if it's self-defense it was so
different that's a whole different thing
yes but i i honestly used to think i i
used to at one point thing never hit a
woman like that was my yeah i really did
until i saw how these [ __ ] be hitting
i was like i thought they were like hey
like a play fight no no no full
well you're gonna come at him like a man
expect to get decked like a man
like what the what are you doing i think
a lot of that as well for some women
that attack men or whatever the
situation is trauma
mental health
the way that you've been brought up your
characteristics a lot of that stuff does
play a part into it as well it's not
just a case of oh yeah i'm gonna do this
because i can get away with it because
i'm a woman
you know i've
personally been in some
volatile
relationships situations no i don't
think that it's
okay to hit anyone but i know personally
i've had some authentications because of
past trauma yeah
there's no really way to put it into
words but you just your mind takes you
to a place and it's not that oh yeah i
think i can hit a man it's just you like
go into
mad mode i just
pump it any other way than that wait so
did you hit him so let's say for example
i've had a past relationship where you
know there was domestic violence
involved um fast forward into a new
relationship because i
didn't allow myself to heal didn't give
myself closure i had ptsd and issues
that i didn't even realize i was not
working through so
when a particular argument would happen
with my new partner it's like i was
waiting for some sort of reaction that i
wasn't going to get
so that just made me
act out but again that was down to
me not getting the closure and dealing
with trauma when i was in denial what
did you say act out do you mean hit him
or was it like well it was a very
volatile relationship um the previous
one right but the new guy when he used
to yell
i just used to feel that oh my god
something's about to happen so i kind of
want to get in there first now that's by
no means okay to put your hands on
anyone but yeah unfortunately that's the
sad truth of some of my past certain
situations that have happened that have
made me
overreact and you know do you know
what's interesting though in this
situation like if you were a dude saying
the same thing i feel like the reaction
would be completely different yeah like
you know i mean like if he said like oh
because of my trash trauma i felt like
she was to come at me first so i like i
ducked her i hit her yeah it's just
interest like like this is just
like and i'm not trying to like you know
shame you know but it's just it's just
like i think that's how our society is
is it's very like woman-centric yes and
it almost allows us to like get away
with bad behavior yeah most definitely
like i'd be the first to say i don't
condone any of that yeah bad behavior
whatsoever but i have to be
um a realist and accept the fact that a
b and c could have happened because i
didn't internally deal with some of my
issues and it's all down to me it's not
down to the other person it's not even
down to my ex who did whatever he did to
me it comes down to me really so that's
like healing that i had to
find for myself yeah and that's that's
good because a lot of girls will
continue to blame other people instead
of like taking that accountability yeah
you can't yeah but before in the society
it was men centric as well
now it's women centric if you if you
think that you know if you think through
actually back in the day it was meant
century and still there's a lot of power
how would you say it was men centric
back in the day
uh because women they would not have the
right
i mean to work they would stay like at
home being a housewife they would be
mothers and they had to clean they had
to cook and shut up
they would never had the power to choose
a lot of stuff the men would they would
the men had to give permission you know
this is like back back in the day i'm
saying you realize they got to stay home
and they got to not work
that's that's a privilege to be a
housewife that's a privilege that's a
privilege for a lot of women out there
but not all women i think everyone
there's there's accounts of girls in the
1800s in the us becoming like
millionaires self-made
yeah
i mean
everyone is different and just because
we are women doesn't mean that we want
the same thing you know there's a lot of
women they don't want to have kids
there's a lot of women that want to
marry and that's okay and we need to
accept that because just because you are
a woman it doesn't mean that you have to
be a housewife because you are a man it
doesn't mean that you have to be a
husband there's a lot of people out
there is this is not about gender it's
about humans and humans are complicated
and we are all different and we have
different ones well okay and we have to
accept that so i'm just going to throw
some numbers at you okay so the average
person no no no so this is just i think
this is a reality that a lot of women
don't know
and i think a lot of people like think
like like think like you i don't fault
you for that but okay you realize the
average person needs 2.5 million to
retire so if you want to retire at 65
and you don't want to work the rest of
your life you need 2.5 million so that
means that 65 if you if you
want enough money to not be you know
taken out by a cancer diagnosis or
something and you can't do that unless
you make
i don't know the exact number but it's
about it's about six figures or more
and you need two incomes to do that
and another like thing that people don't
know is that women that don't have kids
and don't get married they're
statistically one of the most unhappy
groups
but it's their choice
not just no no i'm not it's not judging
it's like giving girls the information
because because we a lot of times in
society we'll say oh don't judge like do
what you want and i'm and i'm all for
that if a girl wants to do that but if
you end up homeless and alone i don't
think you're going to be very happy and
a lot of women are heading towards that
because they're not prioritizing family
there's a lot of men as well doing that
you know there's a lot of men now they
are probably going to places or not
and they don't want a girl they don't
want girl they want girlfriends actually
they want wives yes they do exactly they
want wives in plural not seeing they
don't want a wife they want wife well
okay so another does that make sense
another stat that a lot of people don't
know is that it's a very small
percentage of men that have access to
all of the women so when women talk
about 80 of women if you ask them what
they want in a man and what they would
need to like marry a dude or be with a
dude they list 20 of men and that's on
the high end sometimes it's 5 percent
sometimes it's 10 sometimes it's 15
so the men that you're talking about
that want three wives um the majority of
men would be happy with any wife
they would just be happy with anyone
because the majority one in three men
under 30 aren't haven't slept with
anyone in the past year or are virgins
yeah so so men but the thing is men
historically have been lonely like men
men historically don't always reproduce
because historically only 40 percent of
men reproduced where 80 of women did
so
like like that that's normal for i'm not
saying it's okay or right like but like
that's that's normal throughout history
what's not normal is telling women to
like chase the bad priority prioritize a
career over a family and then
now she's 60 alone and homeless
and
all because like she was given the wrong
advice
yeah she's homeless
yeah because you need 2.5 million to
retire so if you're like let's say you
stay by yourself and you make it to 60
or 65 okay
and you get a cancer diagnosis that will
put you on the street
or you get or you get you know you have
too much debt like the other issue is
that women own the majority of debt so
i don't remember the exact stat but it's
like 75 to 80 of debt is owned by women
so this is this is the path and half of
women over 30 are single and childless
and 90 of your eggs are gone by 30. so
the path that a lot of women are taking
is to be homeless they're the largest
growing number of homeless
population